ladies and gentlemen we are very quickly
approaching a full-scale european war
between russia and ukraine in just a
period of a few hours things went from
u.s intelligence believes
large invasion is coming within the next
48 hours and then just a few hours later
uh bombings starting all over ukraine by
russia
further russian troops entering ukraine
and we are now in the middle of a
full-scale invasion of ukraine by
russian president vladimir putin there
were still people even up until minutes
before
saying this is not likely to happen it's
not likely it just doesn't seem like
it's what putin wants to do
and yet it is what's happening and we
are doing the best we can to keep up
with all of the news which is changing
very quickly let's just start somewhere
with the headline russia invades ukraine
in europe's darkest hours since world
war ii reported by reuters russian
forces invaded ukraine thursday and
understand that
it was wednesday night in the us being
seven hours later in ukraine it was
early thursday morning
in a mass assault by land sea and air
the biggest attack by one state against
another in europe since world war ii
missiles rain down
ukraine reported columns of troops
pouring across its borders from russia
and belarus and landing on the coast
from the black and azov seas
ukrainian troops fought russian forces
along practically the entire border
explosions were heard before dawn and
throughout the morning in the capital
kiev
three million people in the city gunfire
rattled sirens blared and the highway
out of the city choked with traffic as
residents fled
um
russia attacks ukraine peace in europe
shattered as reported by the associated
press
russia launched a wide-ranging attack on
ukraine thursday hitting cities and
bases with airstrikes or shelling
civilians piled into trains and cars to
flee ukraine's government said russian
tanks and troops rolled across the
border in a full-scale war
could we write the geopolitical order
and whose fallout already reverberated
around the world in unleashing moscow's
most aggressive actions since the soviet
invasion of afghanistan in 1979 that's
43 years ago putin deflected global
condemnation and cascading new sanctions
this is now starting to pull in other
european countries in the sense of
triggering nato article 4.
estonia latvia lithuania poland and
other allies are holding consultations
under nato's article 4 after russia has
attacked ukraine under article 4 of the
nato agreement the allies can hold
consultations whenever they feel the
territorial integrity political
independence or security of an ally is
threatened
this is the next signal
of what could be next and what could be
next would be
man i mean it's it's it would be
something approximating
the scope of a world war and and i
i don't want to be hyperbolic but when
we are talking about a full-scale
invasion by russia of ukraine and uh by
russia of ukraine and then we are
talking about the surrounding allies
including estonia and lithuania et
cetera getting involved
how can i not say we're talking about
something approximating a world war
i was going to report to you today
u.s warns full-scale invasion of ukraine
could be imminent this was
again in the afternoon yesterday the
story was we believe the intelligence
points in this direction it could be
coming it could be 48 hours
and then within hours it happened
within hours it happened
um
biden warns russia of further
consequences after putin's declaration
it's going to get very ugly
politically and economically
biden issued a statement wednesday night
condemning russia's president vladimir
putin's announcement of a quote special
military operation in ukraine moments
before ukrainian cities were bombarded
by russian missile strikes consider that
there were people
there were people up and i mean some
this morning are still saying it but
there were people up until last night
saying everything putin is doing is
justified because by not ruling out that
ukraine
will ever join nato
putin is justified in everything the
invasion the bomb everything
got some real real problems out there
a putin sent in troops disguised with
white peace monitor symbols and
ukrainian officials folks it's a full
invasion
troops entering the country from belarus
were reportedly disguising themselves in
ukrainian military and police
uniforms
we have various
locations of where explosions were heard
we have a map up on the screen and as
you can see it's basically the entire
country as of this morning
the western piece of ukraine which
borders romania hungary slovakia
has not yet
seen explosions but you have locations
where cnn heard explosions and then
locations where local residents reported
explosions
cnn reporting that the ukrainian
interior ministry says they have
experienced hundreds of casualties
from just the first missile strikes
hundreds already killed in ukraine the
the vibrations obviously those um
attacks
those missile strikes coming in much
closer and here's the sort of um news
that we've got from you defense
officials uh saying
that
um
this is now and this is a quote i'm
getting from the president's office at
the moment a full-blown nationwide
attack
with military infrastructure that is
being attacked nationwide so the
emphasis being on the military
infrastructure that they say
is coming under attack we've also spoken
to again
our contact at the interior ministry an
ontario ministry official saying that
across the country as a result of these
attacks
there are hundreds of casualties now we
don't know
how many of those people are dead how
many are injured or whether that figure
is accurate but we do know that the
interior ministry of ukraine is putting
the number of casualties so far in this
nationwide assault missile assault at
this stage for the most part
in the hundreds and i apologize i said
hundreds dead casualties does not uh
necessarily mean uh uh dead it means
injured or dead and we're still going to
be standing by to learn more about that
but it is it is not looking uh
particularly good the plan now is for
more sanctions more sanctions world
expresses outrage plans stronger russia
sanctions as reported by the associated
press world leaders today reacted to the
invasion with vows of unprecedented
sanctions
um and we will we will focus in more on
the sanctions
uh in another segment we have incredible
video from uh keeves central train
station just flooded with people trying
to get out of the city desperation
rising and we're showing that video to
our audience just people desperate to
get out
there are reports
of troops coming into ukraine russian
troops from all sides cnn has video of
troops crossing the border of belarus
into ukraine that's one direction from
which they are entering there are
reports of russian military forces
entering ukraine from crimea
making that
uh invasion
from eight years ago
all the more relevant today
uh this is going to be painful for
russia i mean the the russian stock
market down 40 percent
it's it's you know the if retaliation
really gets going and ukraine says there
has been some
we don't know the full scope of it yet
um it is going to be painful for russia
but it's not clear putin cares
um
ukraine's military says its air defense
did shoot down a russian plane in
eastern ukraine
ukraine is saying anyone who's ready and
able to hold a weapon can join
territorial defense forces
and understand that the russians will
want to persuade you ukraine to
surrender and not only are they
launching a multi-origin multi-platform
attack they are also likely to use
disinformation
fake video and fake photos to encourage
that ukrainian surrender and the next
several days could be some of the most
insane we have seen on this planet
geopolitically i don't even i don't even
know since when in a very very long time
and the threats are now starting to come
to the united states
one of our sponsors is cometier coffee
cometier coffee is delicious i can tell
you first hand and they've discovered
the best way to brew preserve and
deliver coffee their brewing process
captures over 000 flavor compounds
then the coffee is flash frozen locking
in the flavor it arrives at your home
frozen in a fully recyclable capsule all
you have to do is melt it by adding hot
water or cold water for iced coffee it
takes seconds it's the most convenient
way that i have ever made coffee i've
been impressed with how the process
protects the flavor i really enjoy
cometier they have a variety of flavor
options light medium and dark single
origin and blended coffee roasts from
the best specialty roasters you'll get
twenty dollars off when you go to
cometeer.com
pacman the link is underneath this video